hi everyone uh welcome to cs224n we're
about two minutes in so let's get
started
um so today uh we've got what I think is
quite an exciting lecture topic we're
going to talk about self-attention and
Transformers so these are some ideas
that are sort of the foundation of most
of the modern advances in natural
language processing and actually uh sort
of AI systems in a broad range of fields
so it's a very very fun topic
um before we get into that
um
[Music]
okay before we get into that we're going
to have a couple of reminders so there
are brand new lecture notes
uh uh nice thank you yeah
um I'm very excited about them
um they go into they they pretty much
follow along with uh what I'll be
talking about today but go into
considerably more detail uh assignment
four is due a week from today
um yeah so the issues with Azure
continue
um thankfully thankfully
um
our uh uh Tas especially has tested that
this works on collab and the amount of
training is such that you know uh you
know a collab session will allow you to
train uh your machine translation system
so if you don't have a GPU use collab
we're continuing to work on getting
access to more gpus for uh assignment
five in the final project uh we'll
continue to update you as we're able to
um but our you know are the usual
systems this year uh are no longer
holding because companies are changing
their minds about things okay
um so our final project proposal uh you
have a proposal of what you want to work
on for uh your final project we will
give you feedback on whether we think
it's a feasible idea or how to change it
so this is very important because we
want you to work on something that we
think has a good chance of success for
the rest of the quarter that's going to
be out tonight we'll have an ad
announcement when it is out
um and we want to get you feedback on
that pretty quickly uh because you know
you'll be working on this after
assignment five is done really the major
core component of the course uh after
that is the um is the final project
okay any questions
cool okay
um
okay so so let's let's kind of take a
look back into what we've done so far in
this course and sort of see uh what you
know what we were doing in natural
language processing what was our
strategy if you had a natural language
processing problem and you wanted to say
take like your best effort attempt at it
without doing anything too fancy you
would have said okay I'm going to have
you know a bi-directional lstm uh
instead of a simple RNN right I'm going
to use an lstm uh to encode my sentences
I get bi-directional context and um if I
have an output that I'm trying to
generate right I'll have like a
unidirectional lstm you know that I was
going to generate one by one so you have
a translation or a parse or whatever and
so maybe I've encoded in a
bi-directional LCM The Source sentence
and I'm sort of you know one by one
decoding out the the target with my
unidirectional LCM and then uh also
right I was going to use something like
attention to give flexible access to
memory uh if I you know felt like I
needed to do this sort of look back and
see where I want to translate from okay
and this was just working uh
exceptionally well and we we motivated
so you know attention through wanting to
do machine translation and you have this
this bottleneck where you don't want to
have to encode the whole sentence Source
sentence in a single vector
okay and in this lecture we have the
same goal so we're going to be looking
at a lot of the same problems that we
did previously but we're going to use
different building blocks we're going to
say
um you know uh if if 2014 to 2017-ish I
was using recurrence uh through lots of
trial and error years later uh it was we
had these like brand new building blocks
that we could plug in sort of you know
uh direct replacement for lstms and
they're going to allow for just a huge
range of much more successful
applications and um and so what what are
the what what are the issues with the
recurrent neural networks we used to use
and what are the new systems that we're
going to use sort of from this point
moving forward
okay so um so one of the issues with
with a recurrent neural network uh is
what we're going to call linear
interaction distance so as we know uh
you know
rnns are unrolled left to right or right
to left depending on the language and
the direction okay but it encodes the
sort of notion of linear locality which
is useful because if two words occur
right next to each other sometimes
they're actually quite related so tasty
Pizza they're nearby and in the
recurrent neural network right you sort
of encode you know tasty and then you
sort of walk one step and you encode
Pizza
um so nearby words do often affect each
other's meanings
um but you know you have this this
problem where very long distance
dependencies can take a very long time
to interact so if I have the sentence
the chef
so those are those are nearby those
interact with each other
and then uh who and then a bunch of
stuff like the chef who went to the
stores and picked up the ingredients and
you know loves garlic
um and then was right like I actually
have an RNN step right this sort of
application of the recurrent weight
Matrix and some element-wise
non-linearities once twice three times
right sort of as many times as there is
potentially the the length of the
sequence between chef and was right and
it's the chef who was so this is a long
distance dependency should feel kind of
you know related to the stuff that we
did in dependency syntax but you know
it's quite difficult
uh to learn potentially that these words
should be related so if you have sort of
a lot of steps uh between
uh between words
um
you know it can be difficult to learn
the dependencies between them you know
we talked about all these gradient
problems lstms do a lot better at
modeling the gradients uh across long
distances than simple recurrent neural
networks but it's not perfect
um
and we already know sort of that this
linear linear order isn't sort of the
right way to think about about sentences
so if I wanted to learn that it's the
chef who
uh was then you know I might have a hard
time doing it because the gradients have
to propagate from west to Chef and you
know uh really I'd like more direct
connection between words that might be
related in the sentence or in a document
even right if these are going to get
much longer
um so so this is this linear interaction
distance problem we would like words
that might be related to be able to
interact with each other in the neural
networks computation sort of graph uh
more easily than uh sort of being
linearly far away
um yeah so that we can learn these long
distance dependencies better
and there's a related problem too that
again comes back to the recurrent neural
networks dependence on the index on the
index into the sequence often call it a
dependence on time so in a recurrent
neural network the forward and backward
passes have o of sequence length many so
that means just roughly sequence in this
case just sequence length many
unparallelizable operations so you know
we know gpus are great they can do
a lot of operations at once as long as
there's no dependency between the
operations in terms of time that you
have to compute one and then compute the
other right but in a recurrent neural
network you can't actually compute the
RNN hidden state for time step 5 before
you compute the RNN hidden state for
time step four or time step three right
and so you get this graph that looks
very similar where if I want to compute
this hidden state so I've got some word
I can I have zero operations I need to
do before I can compute this state I
have one operation I can do before I can
compute this state
and as my sequence length grows right
I've got okay here I've got three
operations I need to do before I can
compute the state with the number three
because I need to compute this and this
and that so there's sort of three
unparallelizable operations that I'm
sort of glomming you know all the Matrix
multiplies and stuff into a single one
so so one two three and of course this
grows with the sequence length as well
so uh down over here so as the sequence
length grows I can't parallelize you
know I can't just have a big GPU just
you know with the with the Matrix
multiply to compute this state because I
need to compute all the previous States
beforehand
foreign
sort of related problems both with the
dependence on time yeah yeah so I have a
question on the linear interaction
issues I thought that was the whole
point of the attention Network and then
how maybe um you want during the
training of the actual cells that depend
more on each other can't we do something
like the attention and sort of work our
way
so the question is uh with the linear
interaction distance wasn't this sort of
the point of attention that it sort of
gets around that can't we use something
with attention to sort of help or does
that just help so it won't solve the
paralyzability problem and in fact
everything we do in the rest of this
lecture will be attention-based but
we'll get rid of the recurrence and just
do attention more or less so well yeah
it's a great intuition
any other questions
Okay cool so
um
so if not recurrence what about
attentions even just a slide a slide
back
um and uh so you know just we're gonna
get deep into attention today but just
for the second right attention treats
each word's representation as a query to
access and incorporate information from
a set of values so previously right we
were in a decoder we were decoding out a
translation of a sentence and we
attended to the encoder so that we
didn't have to store the entire
representation of the source sentence
into a single vector and here today
we'll talk think about attention within
a single sentence so I've got this sort
of sentence written out here with a you
know word one through word t in this
case and um right on these sort of
integers in the boxes I'm writing out
the number of unparallelizable
operations that you need to do before
you can can compute these so for each
word you can independently compute its
embedding without doing anything else
previously right because the embedding
just depends on the word identity
and then with attention right if I
wanted to build an attention
representation of this word by looking
at all the other words in the sequence
that's sort of one big operation and I
can do them in parallel for all the
words so the attention for this word I
can do for the attention for this word I
don't need to sort of walk left to right
like I did for an RNN again we'll get
much deeper into this but this you
should uh have the intuition that it
solves the linear interaction problem
and the non-parelizability problem
because now no matter how far away words
are from each other I am potentially
interacting right I might just attend to
you even if you're very very far away uh
sort of independent of how far away you
are and I also don't need to sort of
walk along the sequence linearly long so
I'm treating the whole sequence at once
all right so so you know the intuition
is that attention allows you to look
very far away at once and it doesn't
have this dependence on the sequence
index that keeps us from parallelizing
operations and so now the rest of the
lecture we'll talk uh in great depth
about attention uh so maybe let's just
uh move on okay
so let's think more deeply about
attention
um you know one thing that you might
think of with attention is that it's
sort of Performing kind of a fuzzy
lookup in a key value store so you have
a bunch of keys a bunch of values and
it's going to help you sort of access
that so in an actual lookup table right
just like a dictionary in Python for
example right very simple you have a
table of keys that each key maps to a
value and then you like give it a query
and the query matches you know one of
the keys and then you return the value
right so I've got a bunch of keys here
and my query matches the key so I return
the value simple
Fair easy okay good
um and in attention uh right so just
like we saw before the query matches all
keys softly there's no exact match uh
you sort of compute some sort of
similarity between the key and all of
the sorry the query and all of the keys
and then you sort of weight the results
so you've got to query again you've got
a bunch of keys
the query to different extents is
similar to each of the keys
and you will sort of measure that
similarity between zero and one through
a soft Max and then you know you get the
values out you you average them via the
weights of the similarity between the
key and the the query and the keys
you do a weighted sum with those weights
and you get an output right so it really
is quite a bit like a lookup table but
in this sort of soft Vector space you
know
um mushy sort of sense so I'm really
doing some kind of accessing into this
information that's stored in the key
value store but I'm sort of softly
looking at all of the results
okay any questions there
cool
um so so what might this look like right
so if I was trying to represent this
sentence I went to Stanford's cs224n and
learned so I'm trying to build a
representation of learned
um you know uh I have a key for each
word so this is this self-attention
thing that we'll we'll get into I have a
key for each word a value for each word
I've got the query for learned and I've
got these sort of these sort of teal-ish
bars up top which sort of might say how
much you're going to try to access each
of the word like so maybe 224n is not
that important CS maybe that determines
what I learned you know Stanford uh
right and then learned maybe that's
important to representing itself right
so you sort of look across at the whole
sentence and build up this sort of soft
accessing of of information across the
sentence in order to represent learned
in context
okay so this is just a toy a toy diagram
so let's get into the math so we're
going to look at a sequence of words
that's W1 to n a sequence of words in a
vocabulary so this is like you know Zuko
made his Uncle T that's a that's a good
sequence and for each word we're going
to embed it with this embedding Matrix
just like we've been doing in this class
right so I have this embedding Matrix
that goes from the vocabulary size to
the dimensionality D
so that's each word has a non-contextual
right only dependent on itself word
embedding and now I'm going to transform
each word with one of three different
weight matrices so this is often called
key query value self-attention so right
so I have a matrix Q which is an RD to D
so this Maps x i to which is a vector of
dimensionality D to another Vector of
dimensionality D and uh so that's going
to be a query Vector right so it takes
an x i and it sort of you know rotates
it shuffles it around stretches it
squishes it
makes it different and now it's a query
and now for a different learnable
parameter K that's another Matrix I'm
going to come up with my keys
and with a different learnable parameter
V I'm going to come up with my values
right so I'm taking each of the
non-contextual word embeddings each of
these xi's and I'm transforming each of
them to come up with my query for that
word my key for that word and my value
for that word
okay so every word is doing each of
these roles
next I'm going to compute all pairs of
similarities between the keys and
queries right so in the toy example we
saw I was Computing sort of the
similarity between a single query for
the word learned and all of the keys for
the entire sentence
in this context I'm Computing all pairs
of similarities between all keys and all
values because I want to represent sort
of all of these sums so I've got
this sort of dot product I'm just going
to take the dot product between these
two vectors right so I've got Qi so this
is saying the query for word I dotted
with the key for Word J and I get this
score which is you know a real value uh
might be very large negative might be
zero might be very large and positive
and so that's like how much should I
look at J in this lookup table
and then I do the softmax right so I
softmax so I say that you know the
actual weight that I'm going to look at
J from I is softmax of this over all of
the possible indices right so it's like
the the Affinity between I and J
normalized by the infinity between I and
all of the possible J Prime in the
sequence
and then my output is just the weighted
sum of values so I've got this output
for word I so maybe I is like one for
Zuko and I'm representing it as the sum
of these weights for all J so Zuko and
made and his and uncle and T and the
value Vector for that word uh J I'm
looking from I to J
as much as Alpha i j
oh w i you can either think of it as a
symbol in vocab V so that's like you
could think of it as a one hot Vector in
um
yeah in this case we are I guess
thinking of this so a one hot Vector in
dimensionality size of vocab so in in
The Matrix e you see that it's uh r d by
bars around V that's the size of the
vocabulary so when I do e multiplied by
w i that's taking e which is d by V
multiplying it by W which is V and
returning a vector that's dimensionality
D so
first line it like W1 and that's a
matrix where um it has like maybe like a
column for every word in that that
sentence in each column is a length V
yeah usually I guess we think of it as
having a I mean if I'm putting the the
sequence length index first you might
think of having a row for each word but
but similarly yeah it's it's n which is
the sequence length and then the second
dimension would be V which is the
vocabulary size and then that gets
mapped to this thing which is sequence
length by D
um why do we learn two different
matrices q and K when like Q transpose
Qi transpose KJ is really just one
Matrix in the middle between that's a
great question it ends up being because
this will end up being a low rank
approximation to that Matrix so it is
for computational efficiency reasons
although it also I think feels kind of
nice and uh in the presentation but yeah
what we'll end up doing is having a very
low rank approximation to qk transpose
and so it you actually do do it like
this it's a good question
so the curry
so I could you repeat that for me the
CII so the query of the word
um dotted with the key by itself doesn't
look like Identity or do they look at
these things in particular that's a good
question okay let me remember to repeat
questions so does eii right for for J
equal to I so looking at itself look
like anything in particular does it look
like the identity is that the question
okay so um
so right it's unclear actually this
question of should you look at yourself
for representing yourself well it's it's
going to be encoded by the matrices q
and K right if I didn't have q and K in
there right if those were the identity
matrices if Q is identity K's identity
then this would be sort of Dot credit
with yourself which is going to be
high on average like you're pointing in
the same direction as yourself but it
could be that you know qxi and kxi might
be sort of arbitrarily different from
each other because Q could be the
identity and K could map you to the
negative of yourself for example so that
you don't look at yourself so this is
all learned in practice so you end up it
can it can sort of decide by learning
whether you should be looking at
yourself or not and that's some of the
flexibility that parameterizing at SQ
and K gives you that wouldn't be there
if I just used xi's everywhere in this
in this equation
I'm going to try to move on I'm afraid
because there's a lot to get on but uh
we'll keep talking about self-attention
and so as more questions come up I can
also potentially return back
um okay so so this is our basic building
block but there are a bunch of barriers
to using it as a replacement for for our
lstms and so what we're going to do for
this portion of the lecture is talk
about the minimal components that we
need in order to use self-attention as
sort of this like very fundamental uh
building block so we can't use it as it
stands as I've presented it
um but because there are a couple of
things that we need to sort of solve or
fix one of them is that there's no
notion of sequence order in
self-attention so so you know
um
what is what does this mean if I have a
sentence uh like I'm going to move over
here to the Whiteboard briefly and
hopefully I'll I'll uh write quite large
um if I have a sentence like Zuko
made
his uncle
and
uh let's say
his uncle
made Zuko
if I were to embed each of these words
right using its embedding Matrix the
embedding Matrix isn't dependent on
uh the index of the word so this is the
word index one two three four versus now
his is over here an uncle right and so
when I compute the self-attention and
there's a lot more in this in the
lecture notes that goes through a full
example
um uh
the actual self-attention operation will
give you exactly the same
representations for this sequence Zuko
made his uncle as for this sequence his
uncle made Zuko and that's bad because
they're sentences that mean different
things
um and so right it's sort of this this
idea that self-attention is an operation
on sets like you have a set of vectors
that you're going to perform
self-attention on and nowhere does like
the exact position of the words come
into play directly
um so uh we're going to encode the
position of words uh through the keys
queries and values that we have
um so you know consider now representing
each sequence Index right our sequences
are going from one to n as a vector so
so don't worry so far about you know how
it's being made but you can imagine
representing sort of the number one like
the position one the position two the
position three
as a vector in the dimensionality D just
like we're representing our keys queries
and values and um so these are position
vectors uh you know you can if if you
were to
want to incorporate the information
represented by these positions into our
self-attention uh you could just add
these vectors these Pi vectors to the
inputs right so if I have you know this
this x i embedding of a word which is
the word at position I but really just
represents oh the word Zuko is here now
I can say that oh it's the word Zuko and
it's at position five because you know
this Vector represents position five
okay so so how do we do this
um and we might only have to do this
once right so we can do it once uh at
the very input to the to the network and
then that sort of is sufficient we don't
have to do it at every layer because it
sort of knows from the input
um so so one way in which people have
done this is look at these sinusoidal
position representations so this looks a
little bit like this where you have so
these are this is a vector Pi which is
in dimensionality D right and um each
one of the dimensions you take the value
I you modify it by some uh constant and
you
you pass it to the sine or cosine
function and you get these sort of
values that vary according to the period
uh uh differing periods depending on the
dimensionalities D so I've got this sort
of a representation of a matrix where D
is the vertical Dimension and then n is
the horizontal and you can see that
they're sort of like oh you know
um as I walk along you see the period of
the sine function going up and down and
each of the dimensions D has a different
period And so together you can represent
a bunch of different uh sort of position
indices and um you know
it gives so this intuition that oh maybe
period maybe sort of the absolute
position of a word isn't as important
you've got the sort of periodicity of
the Sines and cosines
um and maybe that allows you to
extrapolate to longer sequences uh but
in practice that doesn't work
um but this is sort of like an early uh
notion that still sometimes used for how
to represent position in Transformers
and self-attention networks in general
um so so that's one idea you might think
it's a little bit complicated
a little bit unintuitive here's
something that feels a little bit more
deep learning
so we're just going to say oh you know
I've got a maximum sequence length of n
and I'm just gonna learn a matrix that's
dimensionality d by n and that's going
to represent my positions I'm going to
learn it as a parameter just like I
learned every other parameter and what
do they mean oh I have no idea but it
you know represents position
um so
um right and be so you just sort of add
this Matrix uh to the xi's your input
embeddings
um and it learns to you know fit to data
so whatever representation of position
that's linear uh sort of you know index
based that you want you can learn and
the cons are that well you definitely
now can't represent anything that's
longer than n words long right no
sequence longer than n you can handle
because
um well you only learned a matrix of
this many positions and so in practice
you'll get you know a model error if you
if you pass a self-attention model
something longer than length n it will
just sort of Crash and say I can't I
can't do this
and so this is sort of what most systems
nowadays use they're more flexible
representations of position including a
couple in the lecture notes you might
want to look at sort of like the
relative linear position or words before
or after each other but not their
absolute position there's also some sort
of representations that that hearken
back to our dependency syntax because
like oh maybe words that are close in
the dependency parse tree should be the
things that are sort of close in the uh
in the self-attention operation
um okay questions
in practice do we typically just make n
large enough that we don't run into the
issue of course
having something that could be input
longer than him so the question is in
practice do we just make n long enough
so that we don't run into the problem
where we're going to you know look at a
text longer than n no in practice it's
actually quite a problem uh even today
even in the largest biggest language
models and uh you know uh you know can I
fit this prompt into chat GPT or
whatever is the thing that you might see
on Twitter I mean these continue to be
issues and part of it is because the
self-attention operation and we'll get
into this later in the lecture it's it's
quadratic complexity in the sequence
length so you're going to cut you're
going to spend N squared sort of memory
budget in order to make sequence lengths
longer so in practice you know this
might be on a large model say 4 000 or
so n is four thousand so you can fit
four thousand words which feels like a
lot but it's not going to fit a novel
it's not going to fit a Wikipedia page
um you know and so and there are models
that do longer uh sequences for sure
um and again we'll talk a bit about it
but no this this actually is an issue
yeah so how do you know that the P that
you've learned this Matrix that you've
learned is representing position as
opposed to anything else the reason is
the only thing that correlates this
position
right so like when I see these vectors
I'm adding this P Matrix to my X Matrix
the word embeddings
I'm adding them together and the words
that show up at each index will vary
depending on what word actually showed
up there in the example but the P Matrix
never differs it's always exactly the
same at every index and so it's the only
thing in the data that it correlates
with so you're sort of learning it
implicitly like this Vector at index one
is always at index one for every example
for every gradient update and nothing
else uh co-occurs like that
yeah so what you end up learning I don't
know unclear but it definitely allows
you to know oh this word is with this
index said this yeah
okay yeah just quickly in space
um
okay so the question is when this is
quadratic in the sequence is that a
sequence of words yeah think of it as a
sequence of words
um sometimes there'll be pieces that are
smaller than words which we'll go into
in next slide in the next lecture but
yeah think of this as a sequence of
words but not necessarily just for a
sentence maybe for an entire paragraph
or an entire document or something like
that
where yeah the tension is based words to
words
okay cool I'm gonna move on
um okay so
um right so we have another problem uh
another is that you know based on the
presentation of self-attention that
we've done you know there's really no
non-linearities for uh sort of deep
learning magic we're just sort of
computing weighted averages of stuff
um
so so you know if I apply self-attention
and then apply self-attention again and
then and again and again and again you
should get uh you should look at the
next lecture notes if you're interested
in this it's actually quite cool but
what you end up doing is you're just
re-averageing value vectors together so
you're like Computing averages of value
vectors and it ends up looking like one
big self-attention uh but there's an
easy fix to this if you want sort of the
traditional deep learning magic and you
can just add a feed forward Network to
post-process each output Vector so I've
got a word here that's sort of the
output of self-attention and I'm going
to pass it through you know in this case
I'm calling it a multi-layer perceptron
MLP so this is a vector in Rd that's
going to be uh and it's taking in as
input a vector in Rd and you know you do
the usual uh sort of multi-layer
perceptron thing right where you have
the output and you multiply it by matrix
pass it to a non-linearity multiply it
by another Matrix okay and so what this
looks like in self-attention is that
I've got this sort of sentence the chef
who the food and I've got my embedding
for it I pass it through this whole big
self-attention block right which looks
at the whole sequence and sort of
incorporates context and all that and
then I pass each one individually
through a feed forward uh layer right so
so this embedding that's sort of the
output of the self-attention for the
word the is passed independently through
a multi-layer perceptron here and that
sort of you can think of it as sort of
combining you know together uh or
processing the result of attention so
so there's a number of reasons why we do
this
um one of them also is that you can
actually stack a ton of computation into
these feed forward uh networks very very
efficiently very paralyzable very good
for gpus but but this is what's done in
practice so you do self-attention and
then you can you know pass it through
this sort of position wise feed forward
layer right every word is processed
independently by this feed forward
Network to process the result
okay so that's adding our sort of
classical deep learning non-linearities
for self-attention
um and that's an easy fix for this sort
of no non-linearities problem in
self-attention and then we have a last
issue before we have our final minimal
self-attention building block with which
we can replace rnns
and that's that uh well you know when
I've been writing out all of these
examples of self-attention you can sort
of look at the entire sequence right and
and uh in practice for some tasks such
as machine translation or language
modeling whenever you want to define a
probability distribution over a sequence
you can't cheat and look at the future
right uh so you know at every time step
I could Define the set of keys and
queries and values to only include past
words but this is inefficient uh bear
with me it's inefficient because you
can't parallelize it so well so instead
we compute the entire n by n Matrix just
like I showed in the slide discussing
self-attention and then I mask out words
in the future so if this score e i j
right and I I computed eij for all n by
n pairs of words is equal to whatever it
was before
if the word that you're looking at at
index J is an index that is less than or
equal to where you are index I and it's
equal to negative infinity-ish otherwise
if it's in the future and when you
softmax the eij negative Infinity gets
mapped to zero
so now my attention is weighted zero my
my weighted average is zero on the
future so I can't look at it
what does this look like so in order to
encode these words the chef who and
maybe the start start symbol there
I can look at these words right that's
all pairs of words and then I just gray
out I I sort of negative Infinity out
the words I can't look at so encoding
the start symbol I can just look at the
start symbol when encoding the I can
look at the start symbol and the
encoding Chef I can look at start the
chef but I you know can't look at who
right and so it with this representation
of Chef that encode that is you know
only looking at start the chef
I can define a probability distribution
using this Vector that allows me to
predict who without having cheated by
already looking ahead and seeing that
well who is the next word
questions
so it says for using it in decoders
um do we do this for both the encoding
layer and the e-coding layer or for the
encoding layer are we allowing ourselves
to look forward the question is uh it
says here that we're using this in a
decoder do we also use it in the encoder
so that this is the distinction between
sort of like a bi-directional lstm and a
unidirectional lstm right so wherever
you don't need this constraint
you probably don't use it so if you're
using an encoder right on the source
sentence of your machine translation
problem you probably don't do this
masking because it's probably good to
let everything look at each other and
then whenever you do need to use it
because you have this Auto regressive
sort of probability of word one
probability of two given one you know
three given two in one then you would
use this so traditionally yes in
decoders you will use it in encoders you
will not
yes
um my question is a lot about
philosophical
how humans actually generate sentences
by having some notion of the probability
of future words before they say
um
the words that or before they choose the
words that they are friendly
speaking or writing regenerating good
question so the question is isn't you
know looking ahead a little bit and sort
of predicting or getting an idea of the
words that you might say in the future
sort of how humans generate language
instead of the sort of strict constraint
of not seeing it into the future is that
is that what you're okay so so right
um you know trying to plan ahead to see
what I should do is definitely an
interesting idea
um but when I am training the network
right I can't if I'm teaching it to try
to predict the next word and if I give
it the answer it's not going to learn
anything useful
uh so in practice when I'm generating
text maybe it would be a good idea to
make some guesses far into the future or
have a high level plan or something but
in training the network I can't encode
that intuition about how humans build uh
see like generate sequences of language
by just giving it the answer of the
future directly at least because then
it's just too easy like there's nothing
to learn
um yeah but there might be interesting
ideas about maybe giving the network
like a hint as to what kind of thing
could come next for example but but
that's out of scope for this yeah
um yeah question up here so I understand
like the like why we want to mask the
future for stuff like language models
but how does it apply to machine
translation like why would we use it
there yeah so in machine translation uh
I'm gonna come over to this board and
hopefully get a better marker
nice in machine translation you know I
have a sentence like uh
I like pizza and I want to be able to uh
you know translate it uh
Jim
uh Pizza nice
um right and so uh when I'm when I'm
looking at the I like pizza right I get
this as the input and so I want
self-attention
um uh without masking
because I want I to look at like and I
to look at pizza and like to look at
pizza and I want it all and then when
I'm generating this right if my tokens
are like J M La Pizza
um I want to in encoding this word I
want to be able to look only at myself
and we'll talk about encoder decoder
architectures in this uh later in the
lecture
um but I want to be able to look at
myself none of the future and all of
this and so what I'm talking about right
now in this masking case is masking out
you know
um with like negative Infinity
all of these words so that sort of
attention score from to everything else
should be uh net to be you know negative
Infinity yeah does that answer your
question great
okay let's move ahead
um okay
so so that was our last big uh sort of
building block uh issue with
self-attention so this is what I would
call and this is my personal opinion a
minimal you know self-attention building
block you have self-attention the basis
of the method so uh that's sort of here
in the red
um and maybe we had you know the inputs
to the sequence here and then you embed
it with that embedding Matrix e and then
you add position embeddings right then
these three arrows represent using you
know the uh the key the value and the
query that sort of stylized there this
is often how you see these diagrams
um right and so you pass it to
self-attention
uh with the position representation
right so that specifies the sequence
order because otherwise you'd have no
idea what order the words showed up in
yeah the non-linearities in sort of the
teal feed forward Network there uh to
sort of provide that sort of squashing
and and sort of uh deep learning
expressivity and then you have masking
in order to have parallelizable
operations that don't look at the future
okay so this is sort of our minimal uh
architecture and then up at the top
above here right so you have this thing
maybe you repeat this sort of
self-attention and feed forward many
times so self-attention feed forward
self tension feed forward self tension
feet forward right that's what I'm
calling this block
and then maybe at the end of it you you
know predict something I don't know we
haven't really talked about that but you
know you have these representations and
then you predict the next word or you
predict the sentiment or you predict
whatever so this is like a
self-attention architecture
okay we're going to move on to the
Transformer next so if there are any
questions yeah
other way around uh we will use masking
for decoders where I want to decode out
a sequence where I have an informational
constraint where to represent this word
properly I cannot have the information
of the future
right yeah okay
okay
great uh so now let's talk about the
Transformers so what I've what I've
pitched to you is what I call a minimal
self-attention architecture
uh and um
you know I quite I quite like pitching
it that way but really no one uses the
architecture that was just up on the
slide the previous uh slide it it
doesn't work quite as well as it could
and there's a bunch of sort of important
details that we'll talk about now that
goes into the Transformer but what I
would hope though to sort of
um have you take away from that is that
the Transformer architecture as I'll
present it now is uh not necessarily the
end point of our search for better and
better ways of representing language
even though it's now ubiquitous and has
been for a couple of years so so think
about these sort of ideas of of the
problems of using self-attention
um and maybe ways of fixing some of the
issues with Transformers
okay so a Transformer uh decoder is how
we'll build systems like language models
right and so we've discussed this it's
like our decoder uh with our
self-attention only sort of minimal
architecture it's got a couple of extra
components some of which I've grayed out
here that will go over one by one the
first uh that's actually different is
that we'll replace uh our self-attention
with masking with masked multi-head
self-attention this ends up being
crucial it's probably the most important
uh distinction between the Transformer
and this sort of minimal architecture
that I've presented
so let's come back to our toy example of
attention where we've been trying to
represent the word learned in the
context of the sequence I went to
Stanford cs224n and learned
um and I was sort of giving these teal
bars to say oh maybe intuitively you
look at various things to build up your
representation of learned
um but you know really there are varying
ways in which I want to look back at the
sequence to see varying sort of aspects
of of information that I want to
incorporate into my representation so
maybe in this way I sort of want to look
at Stanford cs224n
because like oh it's like entities like
it it you learn different stuff at
Stanford cs224n than you do it other
courses or other universities or
whatever right and so maybe I want to
look here for this reason
and maybe you know there's in another
sense I actually want to look at the
word learned and I want to look at I you
know I went and learned right is he sort
of like maybe syntactically relevant
words right like it's very different
reasons for which I might want to look
at different things in the sequence
and so trying to sort of average it all
out with a single operation of
self-attention ends up being maybe
somewhat too difficult in a way that
will make precise in assignment five
nice we'll do a little bit more math uh
um okay so uh any questions about this
in this intuition
um
yeah so uh it should be an application
of attention just as I've presented it
uh right so one independent Define the
keys to find the queries to find the
values I'll Define it more precisely
here but think of it as I do attention
once
and then I do it again with different
like being able different parameters
being able to look at different things
Etc
we do not okay so the question is if we
have two separate sets of Weights try to
learn say to do this and and to do that
how do we ensure that they learn
different things uh we do not ensure
that they hope that they learn different
things and in practice they do uh
although not perfectly uh so it ends up
being the case that you have some
redundancy and you can sort of like cut
out some of these but that's sort of out
of scope for this but we sort of Hope
just like we hope that different sort of
dimensions in our feed forward layers
will learn different things because of
lack of symmetry and whatever that uh we
hope that the heads will start to
specialize and that will mean they'll
specialize even more and yeah
okay
all right so in order to discuss
multi-head self-attention well we really
need to talk about the matrices how
we're going to implement this in gpus
efficiently we're going to talk about
the sequence stacked form of attention
um so we've been talking about each word
sort of individually as a vector in
dimensionality D but you know really
we're going to be working on these as as
big matrices that are stacked so I take
you know all of my word embeddings X1 to
xn and I stack them together and now I
have a big Matrix that is in
dimensionality r n by D
okay and uh now with my matrices k q and
V I can just multiply them sort of on
this side of X so X is RN by d k is our
d by D so n by D times d by D gives you
uh n by D again so I can just compute a
big you know Matrix multiply on my whole
sequence to multiply each one of the
words with my key query and value
matrices very efficiently right so this
is sort of this vectorization idea I
don't want to for Loop over the sequence
I represent the sequence as a big Matrix
and I just do one big Matrix multiply
then the output is defined as this sort
of inscrutable bit of math which I'm
going to go over visually
um so so first we're going to take the
key query dot products in one Matrix so
we've got um
we've got X Cube which is uh RN by D
and I've got x k transpose which is our
d by n so n by d d by n this is
Computing all of the e i JS these scores
for self-attention right so this is all
pairs of attention scores computed in
one big Matrix multiply
okay so this is this big Matrix here
next I use the softmax right so I
softmax this over uh the second
dimension the second n Dimension
um and I get my sort of normalized
scores and then I multiply with XV so
this is an N by n Matrix multiplied by
an N by D Matrix
and what do I get well this is just
doing the weighted average right so this
is one big weighted average contribution
on the whole Matrix giving me my whole
self-attention output and r n by D right
so I've just restated identically the
self-attention operations but computed
in terms of matrices so you could do
this efficiently on a GPU
okay uh so multi-headed attention this
is going to give us and it's going to be
important to compute this in terms of
the matrices which we'll see this is
going to give us the ability to look in
multiple places at once for different
reasons so sort of you know first
self-attention looks where this dot
product here is high
right this x i the Q Matrix the key
Matrix uh but
um maybe we want to look in different
places for different reasons so we
actually Define multiple query key and
value matrices so I'm going to have a
bunch of heads I'm going to have 8 H
self-attention heads and for each head
I'm going to Define an independent query
key and value Matrix and I'm going to
say that it's its shape is going to map
from the model dimensionality to the
model dimensionality over H so each one
of these is doing projection down to a
lower dimensional space uh this is going
to be for computational efficiency and
um
I'll just apply self-attention sort of
independently for each output so this
equation here is identical to the one we
saw for single-headed self-attention
except we've got the sort of L indices
everywhere
so I've got this lower dimensional thing
I'm mapping to a lower dimensional space
and then I do have my lower dimensional
value Vector there so my output is an r
d by H but really you're doing exactly
the same kind of operation I'm just
doing it h different times and then you
combine the outputs so I've done sort of
look in different places with the
different key query and value matrices
and then I to get each of their outputs
and then I concatenate them together
right so each one is dimensionality d by
H and I concatenate them together and
then sort of mix them together with the
final linear transformation
and so uh each head gets to look at
different things and construct their
value vectors differently and then I
sort of combine the result altogether at
once
okay let's go through this visually
because it's at least helpful for me
um so uh right it's actually not more
costly to do this really than it is to
compute a single head of self-attention
and we'll see through the pictures
so you know we were in single-headed
self-attention we computed xq and in
multi-headed self-attention we'll also
compute X cubed the same way
so xq is r and by D
and then we can reshape it into our n
that's sequence length times the number
of heads times the model dimensionality
over the number of heads so I've just
reshaped it to say now I've got you know
a big three axis tensor the first axis
is the sequence length the second one is
the number of heads the third is this
reduced model dimensionality
and that costs nothing right and do the
same thing for x and V and then I
transpose so that I've got the head axis
as the first axis and now I can compute
all my other operations with the head
axis kind of like a batch
so what does this look like in uh in
practice like instead of having one big
xq Matrix that's Model dimensionality D
I've got like in this case three x Cube
matrices of Model dimensionality D by 3
D by three D by three same thing with
the key Matrix here
so everything looks almost identical
it's just a reshaping of the tensors and
now right at the output of this I've got
three sets of attention scores right
just by doing this reshape and the cost
is that well you know each of my
attention heads has only a d by H Vector
to work with instead of a d dimensional
Vector to work with right so I get the
output I get these three uh sets of
pairs of scores
I compute the softmax independently for
each of the three and then I have three
uh value matrices there as well each of
them lower dimensional and then finally
right I get my three different output
vectors and if I have a final linear
transformation to sort of
mush them together and I get an output
and in summary what this allows you to
do is exactly what I gave in the toy
example which was I can have each of
these heads look at different parts of a
sequence for different reasons
so this is at a given uh block right
like all of these attention heads are
for a given Transformer block a next
block would also could also have three
attention pins the question is uh are
all of these four a given block and
we'll talk about a block again but this
block was this sort of pair of
self-attention and feed forward Network
so you do like self-attention feed
forward that's one block another block
is another self-attention another feed
forward and the question is are the
parameters shared between the blocks or
not generally they are not shared you'll
have independent parameters at every
block although there are some exceptions
is it typically the case that you have
the same number of like heads at each
block or do you vary the number of heads
across blocks you have this
you definitely could vary it people
haven't found reason to there so the
question is do you have different
numbers of heads across the different
blocks uh or do you have the same number
of heads across all blocks you know the
simplest thing is to just have it be the
same everywhere which is what people
have done I haven't yet found a good
reason to vary it but well
it could be interesting it's definitely
the case that you know after training
these networks you can actually just
totally zero out remove some of the
attention heads and I'd be curious to
know if uh you could remove more or less
depending on the like layer index which
might then say Oh we should just have
fewer but it's again it's not actually
more expensive to have a bunch so people
tend to instead set the number of heads
to be roughly so that you have like a
reasonable number of Dimensions per head
given the total Model dimensionality D
that you want so for example I might
want at least 64 Dimensions per head
which if D is you know 128 that tells me
how many heads I'm going to have roughly
so people tend to scale the number of
heads up with the model dimensionality
excuse by slicing it in different
columns you're reducing the rank of the
final Matrix right yeah this but that
doesn't really have any effect on the
results so the question is by having
these sort of reduced xq and uh uh XK
matrices right this is a very low rank
approximation this little sliver in this
little sliver defining this whole big
matrix it's very low rank is that not
bad
in practice no I mean again it's sort of
the reason why we limit the number of
heads depending on the model
dimensionality because you you know you
want intuitively at least some number of
Dimensions so you know 64 is sometimes
done 128 something like that
um but you know if you're not giving
each head too much to do and it's got
sort of a simple job you've got a lot of
heads it ends up sort of being okay at
the very all we really know is that
empirically it's way better to have more
heads than like one
uh yes
um I'm wondering have there been studies
to see if
um information in one of the sets of the
attention scores like information that
one of them learns is consistent and
like
um related to each other or
so the question is have there been
studies to see if there's sort of
consistent information encoded by the
attention heads and you know yes
actually there's been quite a lot of
sort of study and interpretability and
Analysis of these models to try to
figure out what roles what sort of
mechanistic roles each of these heads
takes on and uh there's quite a bit of
exciting results there around some
attention heads you know learning to
pick out sort of the you know it's like
syntactic dependencies or maybe doing
like a sort of a global averaging of
context
um the question is quite nuanced though
because in a deep Network it's unclear
and we should talk about this more
offline but it's unclear if you look at
a word 10 layers deep in a network what
you're really looking at because it's
already Incorporated context from
everyone else and it's a little bit
unclear active area of research but I
think I should move on uh now to uh keep
discussing Transformers but yeah if you
want to talk more about it I'm happy to
um okay so so uh another sort of uh hack
that I'm going to toss in here I mean
maybe they wouldn't call it hack but you
know it's a nice little method to
improve things it's called scaled dot
product attention so one of the issues
with this sort of key query value
self-attention is that when the model
dimensionality becomes large the dot
products between vectors even random
vectors tend to become uh large
and when that happens the inputs to the
softmax function can be very large
making the gradients small so
intuitively if you have two random
vectors in Model dimensionality D and
you just dot product them together as D
grows their dot product grows an
expectation to be very large and so you
know you sort of want to start out with
everyone's attention being very uniform
very flat sort of look everywhere but if
some dot products are very large then
you know learning will be inhibited and
so what you end up doing is you just
sort of for each of your heads uh you
know you just sort of divide all the
scores by this constant that's
determined by the model dimensionality
so as the vectors grow very large their
dot products don't at least at an
initialization time so this is sort of
like a nice little
um
you know important but but maybe not uh
like yeah it's it's important to know
um and uh so that's called scale dot
product attention from here on out we'll
just assume that we do this you know
it's quite easy to implement you just do
a little division in all of your uh
computations
okay so so now in the Transformer
decoder we've got a couple of other
things that I have un uh faded out here
um we have two big optimization tricks
or optimization methods I should say
really because these are quite important
that end up being very important we've
got residual connections and layer
normalization and in Transformer
diagrams that you see sort of around the
web they're often uh written together as
this ad and Norm box and in practice in
the Transformer decoder I'm going to you
know apply mask multi-head attention and
then do this sort of optimization add a
norm then I'll do a feed forward
application and then add a norm so you
know this is quite important so let's go
over these two individual uh components
the first is residual connections I mean
we've I think we've talked about
residual connections before right well
it's worth doing it again
um uh but you know it's really a good
trick to help models train better
um so just to recap right we're going to
take instead of having this sort of you
have a layer uh layer I minus one and
you pass it through a thing maybe it's
self-attention maybe it's a feed forward
Network now you've got layer I
I'm going to add the result of layer I
uh to this sort of to its input here so
now I'm saying I'm just going to compute
the layer and I'm going to add in the
input to the layer so that I only have
to learn the residual from the previous
layer right so I've got this sort of
connection here it's often written as
this it's sort of like oh
connection
okay right goes around and you should
think that the gradient is just really
great through the residual connection
right like ah you know if I've got
Vanishing or exploding gradients
Vanishing gradients through this layer
well I can at least learn everything
behind it because I've got this residual
connection where the where the gradient
is one because it's the identity
um this is really nice and you know it
also maybe is like a buy at least at
initialization everything looks a little
bit like the identity function now right
because if the contribution of the layer
is somewhat small because all of your
weights are small and I have the
addition from the input maybe the whole
thing looks a little bit like the
identity which might be a good sort of
place to start
and you know there are really nice
visualizations I just love this
visualization uh right so this is your
like lost landscape right so you're
gradient descent and you're trying to
Traverse the mountains of the Lost
landscape this is like the parameter
space and down is better in your lost
function and it's really hard so you get
stuck in some local Optima and you can't
sort of find your way to to get out and
then this with residual connections I
mean come on you just sort of walk down
I mean it's not actually I guess really
how it works all the time but I really
love this it's great
okay
um so yeah we've seen residual
connections we should move on to layer
normalization
um so layer Norm uh is another thing to
help your model train faster
um and you know there's
the intuitions around layer
normalization
um and sort of the empiricism of it
working very well maybe aren't perfectly
like uh let's say connected but
you know you should imagine I suppose
um that we want to uh say you know this
variation within each layer things can
get very big things can get very small
uh that's not actually informative
because of you know variations between
um maybe the the gradients or you know
I've got sort of weird things going on
in my layers that I can't totally
control I haven't been able to sort of
make everything behave sort of nicely
where everything stays roughly the same
Norm maybe some things explode maybe
some things shrink
um
and I want to cut down on sort of
uninformative variation
um in between layers so I'm going to let
X and r d be an individual word Vector
in the model so this is like at a single
a single index one vector
and what I'm going to try to do is just
normalize it
normalize it in the sense of it's got a
bunch of variation and I'm going to cut
out on everything I'm going to normalize
it to unit mean and standard deviation
so I'm going to estimate the mean
um
here across uh so for all of the uh
dimensions in the vector so J equals one
to the model dimensionality I'm going to
sum up the value so I've got this one
big word vector and I sum up all the
values division by D here right that's
the mean I'm going to have my estimate
of the standard deviation
um again these should say estimates this
is my simple estimate of the standard
deviation or the values within this one
vector
and I'm just going to
um and then possibly I guess I can have
learned uh parameters to try to like
scale back out in terms of uh
multiplicatively and additively here
that's optional we're going to compute
this this standardization right we're
going to take my Vector X subtract out
the mean divide by the standard
deviation plus this Epsilon sort of
constant if there's not a lot of
variation I don't want things to explode
so I'm going to have this Epsilon there
that's uh close to zero so this part
here x minus mu over square root Sigma
plus Epsilon is saying take all the
variation and sort of normalize it to
unit mean and standard deviation
and then maybe I want to sort of scale
it stretch it back out
um and then maybe add an offset beta
that I've learned although in practice
actually this part and discuss this in
the lecture notes uh and practice this
part maybe isn't actually that important
um but so layer normalization yeah
you're sort of you know you can think of
this as when I get the output of layer
normalization it's going to be sort of
look nice and look similar to the next
layer independent of what's gone on
because it's going to be unit mean and
standard deviation so maybe that makes
for a better thing to learn off of for
the next layer
okay any questions for uh residual or
layer Norm yes
yeah it's a good question when I
subtract the scalar mu from the vector x
i broadcast mu to dimensionality D and
remove mu
from Aldi yeah good point
thank you that was unclear
uh sure
is it divided should it be divided by D
or from me sorry can you repeat that in
the fourth bullet point when you're
calculating the mean
um is it divided by D or is it or maybe
I'm just interested I think it is
divided by D yeah
these are so this is the average
deviation from the mean of all of the
yeah
yes
[Music]
mobilized based on the statistics
so the question is if I have five words
in the sequence do I normalize by sort
of aggregating the statistics to
estimate mu and sigma across all the
five words share their statistics or do
it independently for each word this is a
great question which I think in all the
papers that discuss Transformers is
under specified you do not share across
the five words which is somewhat
confusing to me but so each of the five
words is done completely independently
um you could have shared across the five
words and said that my estimate of the
statistics are just based on all five uh
but you do not
I can't pretend I understand totally why
for example per batch
of the same position so so a similar
question the question is
um if you have a batch of sequences
right so like just like we're doing
batch Based training do you for a single
word now we don't share across a
sequence index for sharing the
statistics we do share across the batch
and the answer is no you also do not
share across the batch in fact layer
normalization was sort of invented as a
replacement for batch normalization
which did just that and the issue with
batch normalization is that now your
forward pass sort of depends in a way
that you don't like on examples that
should be not related to your example
and so yeah you don't share statistics
across the batch
okay cool
okay so so now we have our full
Transformer decoder and we have our
blocks so in this sort of slightly
grayed out thing here that says repeat
uh for a number of uh encoder or sorry
decoder blocks
um each block consists of I pass it
through self-attention and then my ADD
and Norm right so I've got this residual
connection here that goes around and
I've got the layer normalization there
and then a feed forward layer and then
another ad and norm and so that sort of
set of four operations I apply you know
for some number of times number of
blocks so that whole thing is called a
single block and uh that's it that's the
Transformer uh decoder
as it is
cool so that's a whole architecture
right there we've solved things like
needing to represent position we've
solved things like
um not being able to look into the
future uh We've solved a lot of
different optimization problems you've
got a question yes
yes
Mass to multi-head attention yeah
with the dot product scaling with the
square root D over H as well yeah
so the question is uh how do these
models handle variable length inputs
um yeah so
if you have so so the input to the like
GPU forward pass is going to be a
constant length so you're going to maybe
pad to a constant length and in order to
not look at the future the stuff that's
sort of happening in the future you can
mask out the pad tokens just like the
masking that we showed for not looking
at the future in general you can just
say set all of the attention weights to
to zero or the scores to negative
Infinity for all of the pad tokens
yeah exactly so you can you can uh set
everything to this maximum length now in
practice so the question was do you set
this length that you have everything be
be that maximum length I mean you know
yes often although you can save
computation by setting it to something
smaller and uh everything the math all
still works out you just have to code it
properly so it can handle so you set
everything instead of the N you set it
all to five if everything is shorter
than like five and you save a lot of
computation all of the self-attention
operations just work
so yeah
um
uh there's one hidden layer in the feed
forward yeah
okay I should move on got a couple more
things and not very much time okay
um but I'll be here after the class as
well so in the encoder so the
Transformer encoder is almost identical
but again we want bi-directional context
and so we just don't do the masking
right so I've got in my multi-head
attention here I've got no masking and
so it's that easy to make the model
bi-directional okay
um so that's easy so that's called the
Transformer encoder it's almost
identical but no masking and then
finally we've got the Transformer
encoder decoder which is actually how
the Transformer was originally presented
in this paper attention is all you need
um and this is when we want to have sort
of a bi-directional network here's the
encoder it takes in say my source
sentence for machine translation it's
multi-headed attention is not masked and
I have a decoder to decode out my
sentence now but you'll see that this is
slightly more complicated I have my
masked multi-head self-attention uh just
like I had before in my decoder but now
I have an extra operation which is
called cross attention where I'm going
to use my decoder vectors as my queries
then I'll take the output of the encoder
as my keys and values so now for every
word in the decoder I'm looking at all
the possible words in the output of all
of the blocks of the encoder yes
yeah
longer because I know initially it was
like the keys and the values how do we
get like a key in value separated from
the output because then we collapse
those into the single output uh so we
well how sorry how will we get the keys
and values out like how do we because
when we have the output didn't we
collapse like the keys and values into
like a single output so the output we
capture those yeah the question is how
do you get the keys and values and
queries out of this sort of single
collapsed output now remember the output
for each word is just this weighted
average of the value vectors for the for
the previous words right and then from
that output for the next layer we apply
a new key query and value transformation
to each of them for the next layer of
self-attention
so it's not actually that you're
here
yeah you apply the key Matrix the query
Matrix to the output of whatever came
before it yeah
um and so just in a little bit of math
right we have
um these vectors H1 through each n I'm
going to call them that are the output
of the encoder right and then I've got
vectors that are the output of the
decoder
uh so I've got these Z's I'm calling the
output of the decoder and then I simply
Define my keys and my values from the
encoder vectors these H's
right so I take the H's I apply a key
Matrix and a value Matrix and then I
Define the queries from my decoder so my
queries here so this is why two of the
arrows come from the encoder and one of
the arrows comes from the decoder I've
got my Z's here get my queries my keys
and values from the encoder
okay
uh so that is it I've got a couple of
minutes I want to discuss some of the
sort of results of Transformers and I'm
happy to answer more questions about
Transformers after class so um so you
know really the original results of
Transformers they had this big pitch for
like oh look you can do way more
computation because of parallelization
they got great results in machine
translation so you had
um
you had Transformers sort of doing quite
well although not like astoundingly
better than existing machine translation
systems
um and they but they were significantly
more efficient to train right because
you don't have this this parallelization
problem you could compute on much more
data much faster and you could make use
of faster gpus much more
um you know after that there were things
like document generation where you had
the sort of old standard of sequence to
sequence model to the lstms and
eventually everything became sort of
Transformers all the way down
um uh Transformers also enabled this
revolution into pre-training which we'll
go over uh in lecture next class
um and sort of the efficiency the
parallelizability allows you to compute
on tons and tons of data and so after a
certain point sort of on standard large
benchmarks everything became Transformer
based this ability to make use of lots
and lots of data lots and lots of
compute just put Transformers Head and
Shoulders above lstms in let's say
almost every sort of modern advancement
in uh in natural language processing
um there are many sort of drawbacks and
and variants to Transformers you know
the clearest one that people have tried
to work on quite a bit is this quadratic
compute problem so this all pairs of
interactions right means that our sort
of total computation for each block
grows quadratically with the sequence
length and in a student's question we
heard uh that you know well as as the
sequence length becomes long if I want
to process you know a whole Wikipedia
article a whole a whole novel that
becomes quite unfeasible and actually
you know that's a step backwards in some
sense because for recurrent neural
networks it only grew linearly with the
sequence length
um you know other things people have
tried to work on are sort of better
position representations because the
absolute index of a word is not really
you know the best way maybe to represent
its position in a sequence
um and just to give you an intuition of
quadratic sequence length right remember
that we had this big Matrix multiply
here that resulted in this Matrix of n
by n and Computing this is like a you
know a big a big cost it costs a lot of
memory
um and so there's been work uh oh yeah
and so you know if you think of the
model dimensionality as like a thousand
although today it gets much larger then
for a short sequence of n is roughly 30
maybe the you know if you're Computing N
squared times d uh 30 isn't so bad but
if you had something like you know 50
000 then N squared becomes huge and sort
of totally infusible so people have
tried to sort of map things down to a
lower dimensional space to get rid of
the sort of quadratic computation
but in practice I mean as people have
gone to things like gpt3 chat GPT most
of the computation doesn't show up in
the self-attention so people are
wondering sort of is it even necessary
to get rid of some attention operations
quadratic constraint it's an open form
of research whether this is sort of
necessary and then finally there have
been a ton of modifications for the
Transformer uh over the last you know
five four ish years and um it turns out
that the original Transformer plus maybe
a couple of of modifications is pretty
much the best thing there is still
um there have been a couple of things
that end up being important changing out
the non-linearities
and the feed forward Network ends up
being important but it's sort of uh it's
had lasting power so far and so it's
it's but I think it's it's right for uh
people to come through and think about
how to sort of improve it in various
ways so um pre-training is on Tuesday uh
good luck on assignment four and then
yeah we'll have the project proposal
documents out tonight uh for you to talk
about